what's up guys okay so I'm willow bloom
for somewhat obvious reasons and I care
about both movement of people and
objects through space and time as well
as movements of people through society
and ideologies coincidentally this
ignite also includes references to
movement if you know what I mean so mind
your sensitivities this is an
infographic one month of my life if you
average the number of miles between
these different cities that I visit and
average them over the course the number
of hours in a year
I am currently moving at ten point five
miles per hour this means that I am
really good at packing bags I can go for
three weeks without doing laundry and
without checking bags and that's what
I'm gonna tell you about today if it
there we go okay so big picture in time
you first need to figure out how you're
getting to where you're going uh-huh
I really like Hipmunk because it does a
visualization of that I also use a cell
phone app called touch Cal so that I
don't book coffee with a friend who's
gonna be halfway across the globe it's
also important to know where you're
going to stay
I hate hotels they give me the creeps so
I stay with friends or sweeties and
barring that in a new city I would do
air Airbnb or couchsurfing and make new
friends then you have to figure out how
you're going to get to these places the
open government has done beautiful
things for transit maps in the US Luffy
is great for Europe and Germany and uber
is totally posh if you want to call a
black card generally anywhere from the
same app you'll see that all of those
assumed an internet connection
sometimes you land in a new place and
you don't speak their crazy Moon
language and there's no Wi-Fi and you
have to figure out where you're going
but thank goodness that when you get
into the taxi that you also don't speak
their language because you're a stupid
American need to say rocket ship and the
driver says hackers and take you to
where you need to be
don't count on that and instead cache
your maps or draw your self one and get
a SIM card as soon as humanly possible
any civilized airport will have a SIM
card vending machine you can stash these
in your GSM enabled phone and I like to
store these in a sorted folder along
with the transit card of the city that's
associated with I also have a friend who
does this with with ziplock bags you can
also store it with the cash associated
with that country as soon as you get
that SIM card which you should usually
use a spoofed ID with because sometimes
they'll tie your ID to the data you're
getting tether your tech don't connect
to sketchy open Wi-Fi except for MIT or
totally fine and use data and encrypt
that data as much as you possibly can so
OTR PGP etc also encrypt your hard drive
just straight up you can even mail
yourself your hard drive your dwindling
rights are even less present when you
cross over borders the cords that you're
using bring extra and I like to keep
mine with binder clips and then clip
them onto my bag that way I can tell
when something is missing which is super
important when you're three cities into
a seven city trip and suddenly you're
out of all of your Android cables Bad
News Bears to keep saying that keeping
your teens is super important you can
pack jump ropes or TRX bands or
resistance or whatever else also pack
frivolous things like comic books so
that you're not just working and
traveling you have to keep something
going I like to pair socks with
underwear and an undershirt roll that up
and put it set of those in a dress shirt
along with a pair of pants that way I
don't get laundry all over everything
and I don't have to think about my
outfit when I'm super hungover those
things should go into your rolling bag
you should only be opening one bag when
you go through TSA so put your liquids
and your laptop easily accessible be
able to balance on one foot for the
amount of time that it takes you to
remove that shoe and know that you're
pantsed
to come down when you take off your belt
embarrassing but true speaking of I
always opt out on the TSA this is all
hour-long talk is not only ineffective
they're also non-consensual and invasive
I have the luxury of having my
physicality match my mentality not all
of my friends are this lucky to be what
we call sis and when you are getting
patted down that's a huge invasion so
that means that I do what is called soft
packing when I go through TSA which is
where you have a flaccid phallus you
place appropriately in your pants that
way I Who am emotionally unattached to
these things can have a conversation
with the TSA agent about their policy
and process before one of my dear
friends has to go through this whole
thing that is how I pack have fun on
your travels
[Applause]